falling down when you're going for an
Academy Award I would imagine you just
play that over and over again in your
head right because you're like how the
[ __ ] did that happen and why do they
have those steps anyways bunch of
horseshit I would give anything to be
able to go back and redo that moment now
why because you tripped yeah like I felt
the fall I would have been a problem
with the Falls that it startled me and
it made me forget a speech it made me
forget to thank important people right
and but also the next year I fell on a
[ __ ] traffic cone so it was like I
was already paranoid like Anderson
Cooper was like Sheila because we faked
it which I actually reamed him out of
that right because I was like you don't
you have no way of knowing and I don't
have that platform but anyway why would
you pay he's a very nice guy yeah but I
was mad but anyway we had a whole speech
prepared it threw me and then the next
year everything would have been fine if
I didn't fall on that goddamn traffic
cone because then it immediately looked
like it was my heels snapped in England
I mean on the Hunger Games pressed where
I fell in every goddamn city did you
really want to win well yeah yeah you're
competitive that way yes I mean in a way
it's silly because it doesn't mean any
one's better than anyone else but I just
wanted to win it's great no are you
kidding I [ __ ] want to win and I mean
I have nothing to win I don't know what
it is I mean I'm fine when I when I
don't and perfectly happy for that I
mean I I don't think I should have won
for joy I think brie and Alicia should
have won that year oh cool were you
upset with your speech do you play that
moment over and over in your head like
just like a big moment I might not ever
get up there again and it was just I
didn't think David O'Russell who like I
wouldn't have that's quite a career if
it weren't for David O'Russell I didn't
think anybody from the movie I wish to
random her said happy birthday
and then like stumbled off you know the
first movie unifying the first movie did
with David O'Russell was silver linings
what great movies and absolutely and you
weren't the first choice right somebody
else had that role my job I was too
young at the time
so other actresses were going out was
the original person that was good I
don't know I don't want to say that cuz
it might make them I could say it there
were many actresses that were you know
that he talked to but isn't it great
thank God
like whoever dropped out
or whatever worse and then you took it I
want and you want maybe to be a great
actress you have to be truly odd because
I found this in your childhood to be odd
you would go to school and lie about
ailments you you you would make up like
you told the kids at school you had a
wooden leg now that's a but you know
most kids want to fit in that is a very
unusual why did you tell the kids you
had a wooden leg and where did that come
from I don't know I don't know why I
wanted to well one I really loved
surgery right I liked the idea of
surgery I wanted to have an appendicitis
attack so bad
Wow I didn't want to be like I hated
field trips because we were all treated
like cattle and I was like I'm not one
of you I'm different and I think I
probably wanted to Gaudi but if it was a
wooden leg so did you limp and oh yeah I
really committed oh yeah I would whole
method and and and this sounds crazy to
me and I'm having trouble understanding
this you were on the school bus and you
said to yourself it would be funny if I
threw myself out of the bus you know
everything
why did why did you do that I was
reading a book called ransom where kids
get kidnapped by their bus driver we had
a sub bus driver that was forgetting our
neighborhoods and drove past my
neighborhood so I stood up and I
screamed to all of the children on the
bus who were all younger than me that we
were being kidnapped to be held for
ransom so they all started freaking out
and then when we we all put our arms out
of the windows to try to flag down a bus
and when a mom and a minivan pulled up
and was like what's going on
I scream she's kidnapping us oh my god
and then I ran to the back and I was
like should I do it never ones like to
it do it do it like I dare you like to
jump out and it was like if I do it are
you guys all gonna come with me and they
were like yeah rip it open alarm goes
off and I just take off running running
running running how fast was this bus
moving when you threw it stop oh it was
a van mom and then I ran home and my um
I was gonna get suspended and then I
went into the principal's office started
crying
said I was afraid for my life and that
that bus driver had no business
driving a bus and I didn't have to do
homework because I had post-traumatic
stress you're a lot of fun am I right or
wrong as long as you're in on the joke
yeah you're a wild child you really
really are yeah but I also have a lot of
anxiety so I'm careful too and I'm nice